when you got into acting did you ever
think about like cuz that's the part of
this whole business that no one thinks
about you go on talk shows and you talk
about what you're doing is that
something used to think about when you
were to sit in being an actor I mean
yeah truthfully I used to sit on my
toilet as a kid and you know I was
watching David Letterman then so I was I
used to just I would sit there and go oh
David what a high honor used to practice
on the toilet yeah I think you got time
alright well just remember this is a
chair we don't want any confusion over
here you know I have a weird question
for you I your question you probably had
this before but the deuce great show a
great show about it's the 70s and it's
it's looking into the porn industry and
I'm wondering when you were preparing
for your role did you go back and look
at 70s porn watched a lot of porn yeah I
did a lot of 70s porn which is like kind
of lovely lots of bushes very very
natural yeah they're you know truly look
like they're making love yeah
you think it was a better era climene
Andy's always said it's the classic era
of a porn I do I can't stop talking
about
I've been thrown out of church so many
times just an top Lebanese porn is there
yeah and so you it feels like Tim you to
you like a more natural heir of oh yeah
the people look natural I mean then like
I said they're making love okay yeah
just get comfortable
you